hi everyone uh thanks for joining us for
this webinar on the bosque programming
language
my name is mark maron i'm a member of
the research and engineering
software engineering group here at
microsoft research and i'm the lead on
this
bosque programming language project so
to start off with i'd like to talk a
little bit about
sort of one of the high level things we
wanted to investigate and think about
during this research so the first one is
this concept of an intermediate
representation in
programming languages and compilers now
initially
these were introduced to simplify the
process of compiling from a high level
language like c
plus plus down into the actual binary
that executes on your compiler
where you might not want to figure out
how to compile every statement in c
plus plus all the way down to a binary
in one step
the idea is you introduce an
intermediate layer that is simpler than
the source
but still contains a lot of the key
features that you want to reason about
to emit optimized code now over the
years
these intermediate representations
started to expand in what they were used
for they went from
simple waypoints to stage the
compilation actually being
very important to writing the optimizer
to building
other tools like verifiers and
refactoring systems
and the the problem is it still remained
the primary thinking about it was as an
intermediate stepping compilation
but the major use of it was for program
understanding and building tools on top
of this
so what we wanted to do is ask the
question can we build
an intermediate representation that is
actually
focused on supporting these other tasks
like
generating very optimized code or
verification
and not worry about the specifics of the
source language what would that
intermediate representation look like
and can we simplify it
so that we are actually can build much
more effective optimizers or better bug
detectors
now the second question we had is
it's one thing to be able to come up
with a more powerful intermediate
representation that supports these
things
but we also want to go back and
eventually connect it back to
this source language right and we don't
want to connect it to any source
language we want to look at sort of what
is the
most productive most flexible
languages that are in use today and
these in our opinion come from like the
cloud programming environment
where they're highly dynamic they have
records they have tuples
they have union types they're very
flexible languages
right and so this is an interesting
question is can we connect
a constrained intermediate
representation to this very dynamic
source
language and as we're doing this
are there features that by having this
constrained intermediate representation
that we can reason about very
effectively
are there features that this supports in
the source language that are actually
much more valuable than if we had a
weaker intermediate language
so with that i want to you know start
and jump straight into a demo and show
you what we have and sort of motivate
why we started this project
so this is an example of a simple bosque
program that's implementing a calculator
application it supports the operations
negate
add and subtract and the main function
here takes
the operation you want to perform as a
string plus
a first argument is an int and an
optional second argument indicated by
the question mark here
as an int as well now
foskey as we said is we really want to
focus on being able to build reliable
software and powerful tooling
so it has as language primitives
requires
insurers and check operations so it's
very easy to add
validation logic to make sure that your
application performs
as expected now we can go ahead and
compile this program to see that it
works
and if i switch over to the terminal i
can
toggle up and say that if we add two and
the output is 5 as expected now we said
we want to do more than just compilation
in bosque
so an example of doing that here is i
want to understand
is it possible if i expose this say as a
restful endpoint
are there errors that might occur as
someone's using this
so we have a feature called symbolic
testing
where i can actually translate this
program to first order logic
uh run a theorem prover in rk z3 on it
and it will search and see if we can
find any possible inputs that would
cause an error
so you can see here that it is found the
case where if we call the subtract
operation with 38 and the value none
that'll actually fail on this check
operation
right now uh we can check that that
actually
is a failing input by switching back to
our terminal
and you can see that it does in fact
fail so we can check that it fails but
we can also add another requires clause
that will check
and if we rerun our symbolic tester
it'll now report that no errors were
found so we can be confident that no one
will be able to denial a service or
crash our web app
if we deploy this in an unprotected
endpoint
so that kind of shows the power of the
intermediate representation
coupled with this high level uh very
familiar scripting style language that
most web devs would be
familiar with so that demonstration
shows how
vosky's intermediate representation is
able to support
sophisticated tasks like actually doing
program verification
and full error detection there using a
theorem proverb
so let's start by talking about the
features of the intermediate
representation that make that possible
um now before we go in
into depth uh just dabosky ir is based
on sort of a standard design for these
compiler intermediate representations
where you take an op code
and all its arguments are given in
single registers so we've
de-nested all functions and simplified
all of the operator
nesting it uses a control flow graph
model
which is actually a dag in our case and
we'll talk about that in a minute
and well you'll hear the term single
static assignment for mini compiler irs
uh the bosque ir is actually a single
dynamic assignment form and we'll see
why that is important uh
in a little bit but just so you have
some context here's a simple
function compiled to bosque's
intermediate representation where we
have
one input argument we start at the entry
block
we assign a temp value the result of i
greater than zero and then based on that
we'll jump to either l0 or l1
we'll perform some operations and
eventually we'll jump to the exit block
where return is assigned either our res
1 or res 2 depending on which block it
came from and this is
common in single static assignment forms
or allows us to do our single dynamic
assignment
now this should be fairly familiar to
people who have seen other compiler
irs now what's going to be less familiar
is as i mentioned at the dag so
in the bosque ir there are no looping
constructs
or back edges and the reason we wanted
to do this
is once you have loops in your ir uh
let's say you want to
convert this to first order logic well
now you need to generate things called
loop invariance
uh which is very difficult if you're
writing a compiler optimization
you're going to need to do iterative
data flow analysis uh potentially
multiple times
and the the end result of all of this is
that if you have a looping structure
in your ir you're either going to have
to pay
increasing computational cost to reason
about the code involved in that loop or
you're going to have to make
simplifying assumptions that are going
to give you imprecisions in your results
now what's interesting is looking at
these loops or loops in general
most of them are actually instances of a
very small set of what we call
common idioms and in the last i'd say 10
years we've really seen growing
antidotal evidence that
most loops are really in these set of
small idioms with the popularity of
libraries like
c sharps link java streams or somethings
like low dash if you're coming from
javascript
that allow you to write almost any loop
you'd want as a simple higher order
function
plus a um a lambda
now interestingly in 2018 there was a
very nice paper that i was lucky to be a
co-author on
called mining semantic loop idioms that
actually applied some sophisticated
machine learning
to look at hundreds of thousands of
lines of code and figure out
how many loops fell into one of these
small common idioms
and what we found is that yes in fact
most
loops do fall into this class of idioms
and
could be fairly accurately categorized
so we initially thought that in bosque
we would leave loops in and just use
these common idioms as templates for
doing the analysis
the problem is these common idioms look
for patterns much like a developer
who would in this code so if i want to
know what this code does i say oh
it goes over all the elements in v it
applies some predicate to each element
and if it's satisfied it pushes it back
to v
prime so just from these sort of basic
characteristics i would say this loop is
a filter
the problem is that's only true if p is
a pure function that returns a bool
someone might write p like this instead
where it's actually modifying the vector
v
as it's processing it that means that in
order to
understand this loop i need to look at
the body i need to do
extra analysis there i need to project
this back into the template
and it becomes not much
it's only slightly better than the the
version where i didn't have these idiom
templates at all
so instead what we want to do in bosque
is look to the inspiration of things
like link and low dash
and say we are not going to support
loops in the source language we're just
going to give you these higher order
operations with lambda functions
now what that means is that the ir we
don't need to have back edges in the
control flow graph
and every loop just becomes a invoke
of one of these higher order functors
which we have a small set of
and then we flatten the lambdas actually
into first order functions
so it's very simple to analyze this and
understand what each piece of code is
doing
the next thing we wanted to get rid of
which causes many many problems in
various analysis and optimization is
mutable state
and this causes two big pain points
one is if you're doing verification and
you learn something about say variable x
and then you make an assignment to
variable x you need to sort of forget
everything that you previously knew
about x and every other relationship
with it so you need to both be able to
assert facts and retract them
for things like optimizers as well you
also need to start producing
things called frame rules about what a
method may or may not change or facts
may or may not be affected and make sure
to propagate this
now these are both long-standing and
open problems with decades of previous
research
and um instead of attempting
like uh to to to come up with a
brilliant new solution where
many many smart people previously had
only made incremental progress
we decided to just force um mutability
out of
bosque entirely so here's an example of
you know a place where it does
cause you problems so here we have a
struct point
and we want to make a simple assertion
that foo of p equals foo of p
now without mutability this would sort
of be trivial because
these functions don't change p at all
applying the same function to the same
arguments should have the same result
but with mutability if foo which we've
sort of alighted the body here happens
to modify p
then this is not true at all so just to
answer these simple questions we
suddenly need to go analyze many other
functions and reason about their
behavior
and of course it becomes even more
complicated when you add in aliasing
because now with p and q alias calling
foo on p may impact q so this is where
we need these frame rules to express
what part of parts of foo may be
modified what parts of q
may be overlapping with those parts of p
and we need to reason about all of that
just to understand
if q of x equals basically old q of x
here
so this is this is a this is a very
challenging problem
and you know if you talk with people
from the functional programming space
they say all of this is much simpler if
values are immutable
so we took that same viewpoint and in
bosque uh
all the values are immutable
um now the next thing we come to is
equality
and this is a very seemingly simple but
it's a complex concept
in many languages that can become very
subtle very quickly
so in most languages you have primitive
values
which are compared by a value of quality
so integers
or enumerated values then you have some
other objects which compared by pointer
equality right which is sort of the
default for maybe user declared objects
and of course developers can often
overload the equality operator
so you have yet a third behavior and at
any point in time when you're doing a
quality comparison you have to sort of
reason about which of these equality
operations
might be the one in use it causes
further problems when we're trying to do
program analysis
so a very interesting thing is
pointer equality uh breaks referential
transparency
which is of the very nice property that
if i
give two uh call the same function with
two values
that are the same then the result is the
same in the case of pointer equality
two objects that have the same values in
their entire object structure but
different pointers may return different
results
so i can't swap say by value for by
reference
without breaking all sorts of things
right so this is a problem when we
introduce pointer equality
it also introduces aliasing which is the
need to reason about whether two objects
point to the same thing
and interestingly from a compiler
standpoint
pointer equality is very useful
if you're compiling or executing on a
cpu
where an object lives at a memory
address and it makes a lot of sense
but instead of compiling to a cpu
perhaps i'm trying to compile to an fpga
or a actual
hardware you know a chip and in this
case the
object is represented not by bytes at a
specific memory location
but by signals on a set of wires and so
this correlation between address and
equality
totally breaks down and so in practice
you have to end up synthesizing an
address that's propagated through
this circuit and then you have to
re-inflate the object graph in just the
right way
and this becomes very difficult to get
right and so
it really limits the amount of places
that you can apply these accelerator
architectures now
instead in bosque we're going to take
the very simplified view
and we're going to restrict equality to
value equality everywhere so there's no
guessing about which version of equality
a given
application of the equals equals
operator might be
further to prevent accidental very
expensive equality
computations on large object graphs
we're going to restrict the equality
operator to only work on a set of key
types
now this might seem a little restrictive
initially but we have a fairly rich set
of
primitive key types so in addition to
the common inter string
we also have things like uuids content
hashes
time stamps many other things we also
allow you to
lift these primitive quality types
to user-defined things so in this
example i have a
identifier point id that is actually a
key value
and it is a tuple of two integers say a
point in two-dimensional space
and so now i can compare two of these
point ids for equality
i can use them as keys in a dictionary
and i can do it very efficiently
nicely enough we also get referential
transparency
so on any function call i can convert
from by reference passing to by value
passing
i can allocate things on the stack very
freely so this opens up a huge
range of compiler optimization
opportunities
as well as makes it much easier to
encode
a givens program semantics to first
order logic in a very
uh clean compact and friendly way right
so as i say here
the quality now matches the theorem
provers equivalent semantics
with a theory of uninterpreted functions
which is sort of the simplest
cleanest way to do this first order
logic encoding
the last major feature of the bosque ir
which is
interesting and turns out to be very
important to being able to do
all of these tasks we want and enable
the understanding of the program
semantics
is non-determinism now in most
programming languages
there can be two sources of
non-determinism so there's undefined
behavior
like reading from an uninitialized
memory location
and there can be implementation defined
behaviors such as
what is the order of enumerating objects
in say
a set or a map now
undefined behaviors are not possible in
bosque because it's a safe language
but implementation defined behaviors
are are often present even in safe
languages and it's because you say oh
you know
it doesn't matter maybe the developer
who's writing the runtime should be able
to define
what how the keys in a map are ordered
because they'll make it more performant
the problem is if we want to then reason
about the behavior of a program
that flattens a map into a list let's
say
now we need to assume that any key
in that map could be the first element
in that list
and if we make an assertion on that
first element of the list we now have
an explosion in the size of the map of
number of cases to consider
so this can lead to a big blow up in the
time that the
let's say verifier has to run but it
also leads to a big usability problem
where
there might be an input which causes a
crash
under one possible enumeration order it
doesn't match the implementation
order you have so we will give you a
let's say a failing input
that doesn't actually fail which is very
frustrating to a developer so
bossky goes and fully specifies all
semantic behaviors there's no
implementation defined or unbefined
behavior
so these things all come together to
make it's very easy
to take a bosque program and reason
about it either using data flow
techniques
or using theorem provers like z3
so for people who are familiar with smt
lib i want to show quickly
this is the example we were looking at
and this is actually the smt lib output
produced
as you can see it's almost identical in
terms of structure
there's very little extra code about
reasoning about equality
so for example when we compare arg2 to
none we're just using
the logical equals we didn't have to do
any encoding about special equality
operator for the bosque semantics we
were just able to take
z3's notion of equality similarly for
any function calls
or operators we don't need any frame
rules or anything complex like this
so the result is a very clean very
compact
set of first order logic that is we can
reason about very effectively using z3
in our case
so the next thing we want to talk about
is
we have a core ir that allows us to do
many interesting things from
uh compiler verification developer tool
space
how do we actually build a language on
top of it that is
expressive powerful and easy for a
developer to use
so the first thing we want to make sure
is that
the developer can write rich and full
computation in it we don't want a simple
dsl
where you can write eighty percent of
your program
in bosque and suddenly get stuck so
bossy is a touring complete language you
can express anything you want in it
there's no worry about running out of
runway in what you need to do
we've talked a lot about theorem proving
but we want this to be transparent to
the developer
so in the design of our our source
language we want to make sure that you
didn't need to know about
proofs or specification language or
learn
some first order logic derivative in
order to
express some condition that was
important to be true or needed to be
correct
we also wanted to make this approachable
by a developer coming from say
c sharp or java or typescript they
should see the code they should feel
comfortable with it
and perhaps within a few days of working
with it they should be proficient and
productive
and finally we wanted to try and look as
far forward as we could we wanted to
think about what is programming
in a cloud-centric distributed world
look like so we didn't want to build a
language that was optimized for say
building a desktop application
right we wanted to build a language that
was optimized
for having multiple services
communicating with each other
perhaps talking to a phone perhaps
talking to some iot devices
and could run on this wide range of
you know computational resources and
distributed execution environment
now to do this we really looked at a
bunch of other languages and said
let's take the best ideas that are out
there there there's no need to
you know ignore great ideas just because
we didn't come up with them so we borrow
very heavily
from typescript and the ml family of
languages
with some careful design to make sure
that these
language features match what the boss
dir can do
we spent some time trying to eliminate
some common anti-patterns that you might
see
uh going on especially in cloud
programming
and we really wanted to focus on you
know in the cloud world
speaking over restful apis what does
this mean for the programming language
and how you work with it
so let me just show a couple other
samples to
give you a feel for what the bosque
language looks like
so here's an absolute value function you
notice it's block scoped
we assign the sign value in a couple of
different places here
bosque is okay with that we allow you to
mutate variables and we'll show you how
later
just not values so this makes it easy to
write sort of
imperative ish code when you need it
we also have this function all odd which
shows bosque supports rest and spread
parameters
so i can call foo with a
three variables four variables however
many variables
it shows how inside we use these higher
order functions
in this case all with a lambda
and here's one that's a little more
creative so suppose i have a
three uh points so they have maybe two
dimensional points and three dimensional
points
and i want to convert them truncate them
to two-dimensional points in the xyz
plane
so this function expresses that it has
this type
of a record of x and y with an optional
field z
so you can pass in two and three
dimensional points and now we have union
type so this could also be
none uh in this body we have
no null coalescing so i can access p
with this question mark dot operator
and if it's none i'll automatically skip
the rest of the operations
and then i'm not just accessing a single
field in p i'm actually saying
take p access the x and y fields and
construct a new record out of this
and then we have another null coalescing
operator for the default x equals zero y
equals zero point
so below you can see we make call this
function with a couple different
arguments a two dimensional point
which produces zero three as expected a
three dimensional point where we've
truncated z and kept x and y and then
none where we return the default value
so i mentioned block scoping and mutable
variables are very nice and we actually
found
that this is seemingly a simple thing
but it really matches what developers
want to do in chunking their computation
and thinking about small parts in a
linear manner and it also allows us to
really
add some creative syntactic sugar that
addresses some common pain points when
you're doing otherwise functional
programming
right so here's our absolute value
function
and it's you see we're actually
assigning the value in two places
and as i said we didn't want to have
multiple assignments to the same thing
because then we need to basically be
able to retract
facts in our analysis so what we do
instead
is we use this single static assignment
form
but since we have no loops we end up in
a single dynamic assignment form so you
see that each variable here is assigned
in exactly one place and we introduced a
special phi function
that allows us after the if to either
take
the sine zero value if the if was not
taken
and the sign one value if the if was
taken and so in this way we can take
a block of code that assigns a value
multiple times and convert it into a
block of code where each variable is
assigned only once
now what does this allow us to do well
one sort of i would say anti-pattern
that we see in functional programming
where you can't mutate values
is the case where i have something like
an environment let's say in this case i
have a
set of strings and i want to map them to
integers
because it's more efficient to compare
two instant two strings
and so i'll have an environment that is
basically my intern map and i want to
add a new string to it
in this code the first thing i'll do is
see if the string is already in the map
and if it is i'll return
the existing integer if not i'll
add that new string to the map and in
functional programming this
i can't mutate the map so this will
generate a new map in
this let n p equals n bad
then i'll return both the in that the
string was in turn two but i also have
to return the new map
and so i end up with code like shown
below where i sort of have to manually
assign this updated environment to a new
variable and make sure i pass it through
to the next call to this function in the
right way and if i get this wrong
i'll end up in turning two strings to
the same in which would be very bad
or perhaps dropping a string that had
interim previously
so this is very buggy and error prone
and requires a bunch of extra typing
instead what we did is we added this
keyword ref
and what ref allows me to do is the
function
will take that variable in and it can
reassign that variable
in the function body so as you see no
longer are we creating
a new environment variable we're just
updating the old environment variable
to the newly created environment and we
return it
the ref also allows the caller
to have its variable named m
modified in the environment as it goes
through now behind the scenes
it does the same unrolling to the
multiple assignment and multiple return
as we saw in the previous value
or previous slide but now the developer
no longer needs to manually manage all
of this so they get this much cleaner
code
where m is declared once it's passed as
a ref parameter
to each call to in turn string and even
as it goes along
and the bottom we can show it is updated
appropriately on each at each point
another thing that we saw as a real
anti-pattern in
especially functional programming code
is the case where i'm going to
destructure a value
i'm going to update one field in this
case i have a point with an x and y
and i want to update the x field only
and copy the y field
and i now need to manually pull out each
field
of the existing object place it in a new
object and return it
this is of course you know time
consuming to type out
and it's also error prone if you can
misorder things
and it can be very difficult if you're
doing this say with objects when you're
past the super class
and you don't know which subclass it
might be and which fields you actually
need to access and which constructor you
need to call
so bossky provides what we call bulk
value operations
to support this case and many other
similar ones so let's look at how this
this works
so we have the same point update code
now we're calling this function
update and we're passing x equals v
update is a special
method that will look at the type of p
look at all its fields copy all of those
automatically for you and update the one
you specify now this is really nice
because
you know if we later decide we want to
work with three dimensional points
we don't have to go and find every place
where we are going to do this
copy extract you know new value the
update function
will automatically deal with this z
point for us so this saves a ton of time
the potential for a ton of bugs and it's
not just for
um you know update a single field we can
also update multiple fields
you can project types out of a given
thing this works for
tuples and objects and it also provides
merging appending projecting across the
whole set so it allows you
to basically rather than plucking at
individual values in objects
to operate them as logically consistent
structures in a very efficient manner
now as we mentioned bosque is really
focused on
correctness and verification so we
wanted to make it easy for you to add
assertions to your code that would be
checked
automatically and help you find bugs
more quickly
a lot of cases if you don't have good
language support for this you end
up with some ad hoc situations where
you're using
explicit conditionals and aborts mixed
in with your regular logic control flow
if you want to be able to turn debugging
off and on
at different levels you need some sort
of static variables that you can figure
and it just leads to a lot of effort
in implementing these and it means that
your
checking logic is actually getting mixed
in and obscuring your actual
application you know business logic that
you care about
so in bosque we provide a very
comprehensive set
of operators in this case we can do a
release
a requires in either regular mode where
it will only be
done in debugger test or you can specify
release where it will always be checked
we have insurers we provide data
invariants
we provide checks for inline assertions
and the nice thing is all of this is
fully exposed to the type checker and
the verification tools
so it can actually make your coding
experience much smoother and help you
find bugs much faster
now there's verification uh
and checking for crashing error
conditions but there's also the need to
handle
non-fatal but error result conditions
perhaps you're writing a parser and you
see an invalid token you don't want to
terminate the application but you want
to express the developer
that this parse failed and propagated on
up
again this can lead to a lot of logic
with conditionals but we provide a nice
way
to validate certain conditions hold and
rather than writing an if we have this
or return operator to allow you to
return a result
error now it's not just initially
finding this error and returning it but
you'll have a lot of logic perhaps the
caller
has the case where it's expecting either
a
success or an error condition and you
don't want to have to nest everything in
if error is not equal to none then
handle the error logic
so this aura return also allows you
to find that error wrap it up in
something new
or even with this when condition at a at
a special check
that is not just for the built-in types
error and none
now we wanted to show this not to claim
that we were the first
uh language to introduce special case
syntactic sugar for handling errors
many other modern languages like rust
and go and typescript
are all adding very interesting features
to make error handling
and propagation faster safer and
easier to help developers build better
code but we did want to show
that these features which are really at
the cutting edge of how
modern programming languages are being
built work just fine in bosque
and actually map to our ir without a
problem so we're
giving up very very little if anything
at all by having this more constrained
ir
so the next thing we wanted to pivot to
though was i think it's a little more
interesting feature that is not in any
languages out there
and actually is an example of a virtuous
cycle
between the more powerful ir we have
and enabling a language feature that is
actually more useful to developers
and that language feature providing
capabilities back to the ir so that
tools using that ir are more effective
so let's look at what we call
type strings now these are a novel
mechanism
for lifting what is often the known
structure
of a contents of a string into the type
of that string
so we have two types and i'll get to a
little more detail in a minute
the first is called safe string and it's
based on using a regular expression to
validate the contents of the string
the second is string of that uses
a user-defined tri-parse method to
validate the contents of the string
and this is useful for when the
validation logic is
too complex to fit into just a single
regex
now the nice thing is having this
information
in the type makes it easier for a
developer to figure out
what the string actually means you know
is it pixels
is it m's is it some other form of
measure these can all be distinguished
it lifts this information into the type
checker so if you try and do something
type unsafe with the strings it can be
flagged
and it makes this structure available to
tools like structured fuzzers
so rather than exploring string parsing
validation logic
they can actually explore the business
logic of your code
so let's look at an example so we have
here a typedef
we've zip code that is um five digits
followed by an optional hyphen in four
digits
and we have a class called path that
provides this triparse method and this
would be
for like a file system path in in
windows or linux
now we can write a couple things so we
can declare a variable save string
of zip code validated and we can try and
assign that the string
ok the type checker will report this as
an error because we can't assign
a raw string to a safe string we could
also try and say
the s2 is a safe string of zip code and
assign it
zip code quote ok so this is the
safe string literal for ok this would
also be an error because the type
checker will
check that it does not match the
specified regular expression
and of course here if you have a safe
string of zip code 98052
this will be okay because the regular
expression includes uh
that that string right um now
for string of you have the same sort of
thing i can declare a path
of dot slash source test and this is
okay because presumably that
will be accepted by my tri parse method
the interesting thing is
this also allows us a very nice way to
declare object literals
so by doing this at symbol i can tell
the language that i want to take
this particular string and i want to
turn it into the associated object so i
can write literal path
objects i can write literal objects of
any type that i can provide a parser for
xml whatever you like without having to
go in and modify the korboski language
now this got us really excited this
notion of
strings are kind of a really easy thing
but dangerous thing to use because
they communicate across the network
beautifully
you can put any data you want in it it's
easy
to write apis with them but they're
dangerous because
they are unstructured and you don't know
quite what you're going to get in there
and when we were looking at how do we
operate what do we want to
do to program in this cloud-centric
world where apis are being exposed
perhaps in different languages and
different services and everything needs
to go over the network
we wanted to think about what was the
right way to have a type system that
would allow you to express these apis
effectively
right and so we wanted to define this
notion in bosque of api types
of what we call api types and they are
types that are understandable without
looking at an application source code
so i shouldn't have to know about your
object model or
whether your java or javascript or c to
understand
what that type is it should be
validatable for changes against an api
semantic version
fairly effectively and it should give a
much more
precise description of the intent of an
argument than just something like
string so what we came up with was sort
of inspired first by
c plus pluses plain old data types these
are data types that you can just take as
a series of bits
drop into a buffer and ship anywhere and
they're
sort of magically parsable elsewhere so
for us these would be things like none
bool int string hash codes
etc you don't have to have a deep
understanding of my application to know
what those are
the next set are called self-describing
types so these would be tuples and
records
this is kind of like json except we can
identify an api tuple as one that only
contains other api types so you will
know you will always be able to safely
serialize and deserialize this
without issues popping up like json
objects that contain
a function or some other thing that is
not serializable
we also include enums and our special
identifiers because these are fairly
compact and easy to work with as well
finally we have what we call lifted
types so normally
a list of t would not be an api type
because i could put objects in it or
any other sort of thing but if t is an
api type then i can also have a list
of t as an api type as well so
this spectrum allows us to describe very
complex
object hierarchies and with
with relative ease and we know that
they're always safe to move on and off
the network
so let's look at an example of where
this might be nice um
here we have from github there get
re repo sorry they're get repositories
rest api
and it takes you name as a variable
which is a string
from the documentation it takes two
parameters type
which is a string of either all owner or
member
and sort which is another string
enumeration
now if i were to implement this function
using just strings i would have a
signature like this where it takes
three strings and then i would have to
go manually validate
so that the username actually matches
github's
restrictions on what usernames can do i
would have to validate the type
was one of the appropriate strings
manually and if i
ever wanted to change this api say add a
new and um i would need to go through
and check all of these places now
with these api types i can define what a
username regex is
i can explicitly do these enumerations
for what the arguments are
and now repos actually takes a safe
string of you name regex
so i can't accidentally pass the sort
argument there
it creates it takes optionally these a
type and sort
as their appropriate enum types and so
it's very clear what this does
it's very compact and it allows us the
opportunity to do things like
put this rest api pragma on there now
this isn't implemented yet but what we
believe you can do
is using this i can actually go generate
that rest api from this function
signature
i can generate all of the parsing logic
all of the basic type validation logic
so that this is all done automatically
for you and you don't have to worry
about writing or updating this code
further since this is clearly where the
enums are
defined we can actually validate that
say i wanted to add another
field to type inu say organization
as my type enum if i go ahead and add
this
we can automatically check is this did
you update the semantic version of
your application api as well and if not
we can warn you that you might break
various
users of this and you can take the
appropriate action
so we're really excited about some of
this stuff that's going on here and i
started alluding towards what we would
like to do in the future
so let me talk about that so the first
one i was
mentioning there was the semantic
version validation right
so can we actually have rich support
for checking if you change say one of
these api types
are you also updating the semantic
version of your application
appropriately now this isn't
comprehensive because you might change
the logic
somewhere in a way that breaks existing
code without knowing
uh changing the signature of your
functions
but in addition to sort of some basic
sanity checks we can do
on say adding enumerations or changing
type signatures
we can actually run our verification
tools to say
you claimed that this was a semver minor
change
so that's only adding new features to
your code if we run
any input on the old version we should
get the same output on the new version
and can we verify that that's the case
so that's for you as an api provider as
a consumer we can also support the
version where if you're going to upgrade
a dependency you can check is it
possible
this new dependency is going to change
the behavior of your application
somewhere
right and allow you to not sort of have
to
update run your unit tests and hope for
the best but actually have great
confidence that
that version update didn't break
anything allow you to do those version
upgrades much more quickly and much more
confidently
uh i mentioned uh sort of hardware
accelerators a little earlier
and this has been a real challenge uh to
take advantage of these
in existing imperative programming
languages
but as you mentioned voske provides some
really unique opportunities in that it's
referentially transparent
it's immutable and these higher order
functions are great
for mapping bulk parallel operations to
bulk parallel hardware
so i think there's a real potential here
i want to talk about one limitation in
bosque that we are really thinking about
is there is currently no i o support or
run time you'll notice all of our
examples took in arguments
produced results and that was it we're
focused on high reliability pure
computation
fortunately morgan stanley is just open
sourcing their
morpher framework and this is a
multi-language system
for building high reliability services
with a focus on transparency
and agility and explicitly supporting
sort of a multi-platform
multi-language world so we've started
working with them
on integrating voske in here so that we
can use their runtime and hopefully
support their vision for building these
high reliability
services and i'll have some links later
but we're actually starting to
get this developed here on on github
and i also want to say these are the
things that i previously mentioned that
we're really focused on
but a big promise of bosque is the
opportunity to unlock
um a huge potential for what people are
doing in verification
fuzzing testing compilers garbage
collection
process resiliency you know real-time
software and everything else so
these are all things that we've
experimented with a little bit and we
think are
have some potential but we're super
excited about
what can happen here and are really
interested in seeing what the community
starts to do
once they can get in and start using
some of the
the ir and building tools on top of it
so i think that brings us to the end of
the talk um
you know in conclusion i want to just
say what is bossy well
it's really an experiment in how do you
build an
ir and a programming language where
supporting
reasoning both automated and human is a
core principle is sort of the the
guiding principle for how it's built
and the interesting thing is that by
making the code easier for machines to
understand it in a lot of cases it's
easier for developers to understand and
use as well
the second thing is that hopefully we've
demonstrated that the ir we have
enables deep understanding of a software
artifact just by excluding some of these
features and making some careful design
choices it suddenly becomes
drastically easier to reason about the
behavior of a program
and we think this is a breakthrough in
what can be done in the software
engineering and compiler space and
we're really excited to see where it
goes
and finally uh you know we also showed
that bosti provides a high agility
developer experience
it supports dynamic types it supports
union types
it supports everything you would want to
expect in a modern language
plus it brings new concepts like these
types strings and api types
that actually provide create a positive
feedback loop because they provide
more information for the reasoning
engine and the reasoning engine through
doing things like verification provides
more value to them
so i want to conclude just with a slide
with a few links
and thank everybody for joining us today
i hope this was
interesting to you and we would love to
chat with you on our github
page with any thoughts ideas bugs you
happen to find thank you very much
hi well thanks everybody for uh joining
us for this webinar on bosque
my name is mark maron i was the
presenter in the
webinar we just watched and it was great
thanks everybody for joining us
um got a lot of good questions coming
through
so i wanted to take a minute to just
elaborate
on a couple of things here um
one interesting one i saw several on
were sort of the type strings
and the api types that were there and
whether or not
these were something specific to bosque
or how these worked or if these could
work in other languages
and i wanted to point out that you know
one of the goals of bosque was not just
the language in the ir itself but also
to see
what concepts were interesting and might
be able to be adopted by
other languages and might help drive
language design forward generally
and this is one feature that actually
seems to work
great in bosque and it has a great
feedback loop with enabling some of the
the testing and verification and
optimization stuff
but it's also pretty easy to extract
that concept and apply it even to
existing languages so
um at our github page we have a
link of other research papers written
and
one of those papers is by some of my
colleagues where they
formalize type strings more generally
and apply it to
java and show how it can be used in
typescript and then also how you can use
it to
do more effective fuzz testing so this
was something we thought was really
great that's come out of the project
already was the ability to
you know define and understand this
feature better and then extract it in a
way that can be useful
not just in bosque or programmers who
are using bosque but to
the wider language design community
let me see so one other question that i
saw come up a couple of times and people
have asked generally
is on like what languages can
bossky target so right now
it basically emits c
plus that you can then compile um you
know into a a
exe that you can run on the command line
as i mentioned in the
webinar presentation one of the key
targets we have
is integrating this with the morphier
framework
to basically allow us to do interesting
io
and make the language more useful uh
people have asked about
wasm that's definitely possible since we
produce
c plus code that should be mostly wasm
queen
there might need to be a little work to
allow wasm compilation but that's
definitely something that's possible
uh the other thing that we've looked at
is integrating this with node.js
by automatically generating native
modules
via the nappy interface so that you can
basically take
some chunk of javascript you have
rewrite it
in boschi and then export that as a
native module instead of an old
regular javascript module and sort of
swap out parts of your program without
having to rewrite the whole thing
uh in in bosque from ground up
let's see um then i think there was
one question uh on garbage collection
and i i mentioned that we have an
interesting reference counting collector
that doesn't need to do as many
increment and decrement operations
as you would expect if you were trying
to do say a reference counting collector
for
java and that's because
a lot of the features that we have in
boschi
give us very interesting invariants from
a memory management standpoint
right so a lot of garbage collection is
building these invariants about what
state the objects have to be in
and what you can always assume is true
about where pointers go
so one big challenge for example in
reference counting
is how do i account for cycles if i have
a
cycle of references then they'll all
keep the ref count of the object they
point to
as positive and i'll never collect it
with a simple ref counting collector
so in a language like java i would have
to not only have my reference counting
collector
but i would have to have a a mark
a marking collector that would
incrementally or occasionally run to
collect cycles that the reference
counting collector
couldn't handle now bosque is
interesting because it is designed in a
way
that prevents the construction of any
cyclic data structure
for example so we by definition don't
need to have a backup
collector to deal with cycles because
they can't exist
uh similarly we also can guarantee
that there are no pointers from new or
old objects to new objects
so that allows us to structure the
collector in a way where we don't have
to have a right barrier
at all for these mutations of old
objects invalidating pointers to new
objects
or changing their ref count that way so
this allows us to simplify a lot of
logic that we would normally have to
deal with
in a collector in a language that has
mutation that we don't have to in bosque
now we have a collector that is sort of
simple and we think we can use these
invariants to
improve that um actually quite a bit but
it's really exciting that this sort of
is not just about you know verification
but some of these simplifications
actually allow us to think a lot more
aggressively about things like
optimization and like building memory
management so
we're excited about that as as well
and so i think we have
one more question that i can elaborate
on a little bit here
um as i mentioned we are doing this
as an open source project so we have a
repo
on github it's on the resource list uh
on the webinar here and for the past
year we've
you know we started this project in in
the open we wanted to develop in the
open
but for the past year uh we've sort of
been iterating heavily experimenting a
lot
um and so it's been a little difficult
for people to get involved
we're recently just stabilizing the the
project we have the language in a state
where we think all of the big pieces are
in place
and so one of our goals going forward is
to make this
repository more stable and more open to
the community
and easier for people to get started
with so um
you know i would encourage anybody who's
interested
uh it's not as
newbie friendly i guess as i would like
yet but you're more than welcome to come
to the repository
uh post issues post questions there are
issues that people can work on all the
way from you know simple bug fixes
and improving the documentation up to
projects that would be
you know research publication worthy so
there's a wide range of stuff
and we definitely want to make this more
stable and want to make it easier for
everybody in the community to engage in
this project
so definitely come join us in the github
repo if you have any other questions or
or want to learn more and i think
that covers most of the questions that
came up here in the webinar
and hopefully it was really interesting
to you i appreciate everybody
joining us and we'll hopefully see you
in the github repository
you